to our top story tonight President Biden
making a huge decision regarding a
Southern Nevada mountain and half a
million Acres around it becoming a
national monument and good evening to
you thank you for joining us on 8 news
now at five I'm Brian Loftus I'm Denise
Valdez the evacuami monument would cover
the southern portion of the state
Victoria Saha joins us from Searchlight
in the middle of it with how those
living in the area are reacting to the
news Victoria
yeah Brandon Denise Spirit Mountain is
right behind me and to the average
person driving by it could blend in with
the rest of the mountains that Nevada
has to offer but for many tribes this is
sacred land that they say they need to
protect Spirit Mountain also known by
the Mojave name of aviqua Ami it's given
to us from the beginning for for us our
ancestors aviko AME is sacred to 12
Native American tribes it is our place
of creation there's no other place no
other Mountain that's it Native
Americans like Linda Otero say they
fought for decades to protect aviqua AME
making its worth known far beyond just
recreational use you recognize who you
are as this human being with the spirit
and that spirit imbues and you become
one with that mountain on Wednesday
President Biden said he will make a week
a National Monument making the 450 000
Acres surrounding it in the Mojave
Desert off limits to any future
developments something resident and
business owner Sheryl Crowe says she
doesn't agree with I don't know for sure
how I feel about him taking that much
land it takes away our ability to expand
it all she says this would also mean
losing out on the opportunity for solar
panels to come to the area which would
have helped her business I want what's
best for Laughlin not what's best for
the state or for
anybody else
now one spear Mountain does become a
national monument it will be managed by
the National Park Service reporting from
Storage light tonight Victoria Saha 8
News Now